also mein tipp vom märchenprinz ist auf
alle fälle lieb dass der so die frau zu
schätzen weiß wenn es warum macht oder
wo macht sicher bist du herzlich
willkommen im neuen video leute herzlich
kommen bei diesem video auch an dave
kommen sie mit ins boot nach einem date
üblich hatte bei diesem video zu stützen
leute ihr habt dem titel gesehen wie er
uns heute zum ersten mal auf island
anschauen
leider leider ich denke für die
allermeisten menschen von laufen gehört
haben dass eine serie von rtl2 bei der
es darum geht das mehr oder weniger
fälle aber dafür in der regel attraktive
menschen zusammengebracht werden
irgendwo villa und dann ist die
sozialexperten man guckt ja was passiert
ja sehr gut dass das erklärt hast weil
ich habe tatsächlich noch nie eine
einzige folge gesehen passt was weiß
nicht was mich erwartet ok und deswegen
leute fangen wir an mit staffel nummer
drei wohlgemerkt es gab schon eine
staffel davor waren 30 gab schon einmal
davor gemacht sind
es gab schon zwei davon davor wir fangen
aber der aktuellsten staffel an und
fangen auch mit dem ersten applaus zu
stoff nummer drei auf dem youtube-kanal
von lauf einen an damit wir quasi von
anfang an vom grauen ab allerdings das
gefühl für alle kandidaten und wissen
genau was abgeht
das gibt mir viel zu sagen seitdem unter
den ersten 20 unter meinen videos mit
einem monat einen 50 euro schein
bestimmt zu gewinnen und jetzt fangen
wir an mit dem video alles
geschmackssache
darauf stehen die neuen länder du suchst
die ganz große liebe habe ich gehört
denn man mit dem wenn du heirat er seine
familie gründet also viel sollte man
dann sein
[Gelächter]
neun sekunden
ok ja also sie ist beil auf island und
sucht den mann fürs leben perfekt wenn
ich mal nicht weiter weiß zeigt erste
auswirkungen auf ein reales ja
es ist vollkommen klar ja ich gehe auch
immer in den laden mehr infos zur seite
eine tolle ausstrahlung haben wir sind
halt die zähne und das lächeln einfach
sehr wichtig braunau event geso eher
dunkler dann willst du machst so
schlecht aussieht
sie denkt dass auf den geräten über die
man mit dem du kinder bekommen willst
also für die zähne da das wichtigste
sind nein es geht um die zähne leute ich
weiß mir auch so was wie charakter keine
ahnung sympathie zuverlässigkeit treue
die zähne und ausstrahlung nicht zu
vergessen außer aber treue ist wohl egal
wir können das gut gehen gut dazu muss
man aber sagen sie jetzt ihren schutz zu
nehmen ich habe die parallele alle
kandidatinnen in so einer kleinen
vorstellung datei geöffnet das hier war
grade eben samira 22 zugbegleiterin also
sie ist noch etwas auf die höheren große
liebe beide auf einen suchen naja
es muss einfach stimmen direkt also die
haben schon mal die gleichen präferenzen
bei männern heißt die können sich dann
auch teilen bei also zumindest ihr der
ersten reihe treuer nicht genau das ist
kann auch zusammenhang polyamorie ja
also das war wahrlich kein problem also
die zehn stimmen
das aufsuchen der typ mann der mit mir
am frühstückstisch sitzt und über
politik redet dass er der falsche
ja ja ja oh mein gott walther fried
fried der typ mann oder auch für mich
der typ frau dass uns die typ frau mit
dem man am frühstückstisch sitzt und mit
dem man unterhaltungen führen kann die
tatsächliche inhalt haben
aber warte ganz kurz schauen wir wer das
ist die devise bonner an hier
denise aus köln wir sind gerade in köln
ihr wisst ihr dass sie können geld
machen können
die nichts denn nächstes 32 und ist noch
mal auf der suche nach ihrem
traumprinzen echte queen echte party
queen und auf der suche nach dem
traumprinzen alles klar also liest du
bist ein normales mädchen also anders
als die anderen mit den ich gerade eben
gerät habe okay du das mal klarzustellen
die moderatorin ist auch sehr selbst
also liebe zuschauer das ist jetzt
normales hilfe wie du bist sowieso eine
andere welt und applaus für diese liga
so bunt alles total schön wie in einer
anderen welt
warum die jetzt noch nicht in doktor
gemacht hat und an der uni vorträge hält
das weiß jetzt auch nicht ehrlich gesagt
nein
aber dann könnte man nicht mehr mit
ihrem frühstückstisch sitzen dann näher
inhaltlich gespräche aber vielleicht
will ich so sprechen zum beispiel über
das die insel so bunt ist ich wollte
ganz eigenes könnte mit ihr aber
vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger
werden also mein schiff vom märchenprinz
ist auf alle fälle lieb dass der so die
frau zu schätzen weiß wenn ich heute
werde ich euch eins in meinem ganzen
leben mitgibt da dann wenn wild leute
also für alle von euch dachten wenn sv
macht dann mach zwei
ich gehe davon aus grenada du weißt ganz
genau was du willst also bei mir muss
der mann auf jeden fall darf nicht zu
allem ja und amen sagen ich brauche
schon jemand der sagt kommen wir
verreisen
ich will kein mann der zu allem ja und
amen sagt ich will jemanden der mit mir
verreist und paypal
das ist sehr amüsiert auch ein klares
profil muss man sagen es ist ganz klare
vorstellung sie besuchten man denn mit
ihr paintball spielen geht und wenn
einer von euch da draußen essen jungs
und ich denke wo alter ricarda mit der
würde ich gern mal zusammen kommen aber
ich habe überhaupt kein wunder also dass
kann ich kann der clique jetzt nicht das
wird nichts
erst mal kurz überlegen aber man muss
sagen die beiden sind schon ein bisschen
mehr so kommen mehr klar mit ihren
vorstellungen also lieb treu und so
immer mit eigener mit eigener
persönlichkeit einem kopf ist schon ein
bisschen besser als zähne abonniert den
lauf idol channel aber vergesst dabei
die glocke nicht
hilft ja das war ein absolutes highlight
wird ein gefragtes wird das video war
eigentlich schon vorbei da kam das ist
micha glaube ich dass mich warten wir
schon gut was mich schon mal brandschutz
monteur aus ludwigshafen
so hat die allererste vorstellung der
mädels leute aber es gibt noch einige
weitere videos es geht weiter mit dem
nächsten upload ja sehen und lisa also
da geht es quasi um die blonde lisa die
wir gesehen haben und asien ist einer
von den jungs wer als lehrer glaube ich
und schon mal hier rein
mein name ist ja ich bin 28 jahre alt
kommen aus memmingen aus dem ein
verrückter man sich erlauben denn die
serie zu ihnen so eine serie zu gehen
wie türkei es stimmt was sagte der
schuldirektor dazu was sagt ein chef
dazu
du bist bei land und frank zappa war
über weltmeister ist die in folge 2 mit
uns twitterst du weißt du hast du nicht
durchgezogen oder 65 jahre alter
schulleiter also kommt so zu jahr später
ist jetzt eineinhalb jahre senken
ich würde schon echt mich gern wieder
richtig erleben
ja das ist so eine sache
ich weiß nicht ob die dänen das
vorgeschrieben wird dass du so etwas
sagen müssen aber pro wer geht dann
ernsthaft mit der erwartung dahin dass
er wirklich jemanden so quality mäßig
kennen lernt also ich finde es toll
legitim wenn man sagt ja und der bock
ins fernsehen zu gehen so das bringt
ihnen meine karriere voran oder ich bin
einfach nur eine lustige zeit haben aber
nicht unbedingt die klügste entscheidung
muss glaube ich wirklich sagen wenn man
dass man neutral betrachtet sind diese
ganzen leute bei laufen schon
überdurchschnittlich attraktiv also mehr
als der durchschnittsmann editions frau
so rein äußerlichen her aber pro also
ich noch keinem zu nahe treten aber ob
die dame so geistig auf der höhe sind
ich heiße ja schon bin 28 den
sportlehrer und model
und er zeigte schon vergessen ich mache
gerade geiles ausschnitt beruht aber ich
bin ja soo 28 und ich bin auch dabei und
meinen pulsmesser habe ich auch
vergessen von meinem bauch ab zu machen
ich habe leider kein t shirt und kohls
messer den ich nicht über den
solarplexus vom bauchnabel aber was
nicht darüber reden welche note gibst du
dann dieser klasse würde eine glatte
zehn euro angehen welche note von 1 bis
das ist glatte 2
aber da fragt man sich wirklich ob es
nicht um geschnitten wurde
ja also nicht ja das kann schon sein
aber es eine glatte 10
ein kind kommt nach hause max was hat es
in der matheklausur leser ist nach vorne
getreten
aber die entscheidung liegt bei dir
jedoch nicht aber für sie hat es
anscheinend ein bisschen runter boom und
dann bestimmt ja ja was anderes fällt
ist ein missverständnis auch dann rettet
sie so insolvenz raum macht dann mach
zwei aber sie denkt sich also klar
gemacht das macht das buch könnte
vielleicht ein missverständnis ok ja
stimmt und weil bei ihr ist es ja so
dass gleich deswegen könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass es zu keinen boom ist ja
ich habe aber die entscheidung liegt bei
dir
ich entscheide mich für das vorerst mal
für leser auf jeden fall
da sich so alter also soweit kein kopf
ich würde mich vorerst so ok bis ich was
besseres findet für diese ist okay aber
auf gar keinen fall irgendeine art von
commitment oder so definitiv nein
das was unsere kleinen einstieg in auf
einen wenn ihr mehr davon an bord da
schreibt ganz kärnten kommentaren dass
mit diesem video ein bleibt addex und in
der beschreibung verlinken hier ist ali
an persönlichkeit vorgeschlagen das
video hier oben könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren wir sind an der stelle raus
leute macht's gut